- Hold on.
(funky music)
- And, here we go.
- Last time I cried, when, holy fuckin-A.
I was in college, and I
wasn't happy in college,
and I wanted to drop out,
and nobody was supporting me.
So, I started crying, and
I was really sad about it.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for that.
- The last time I cried,
I was in middle school.
My teacher was watching Of Mice and Men,
and it was at the part when
George was about shoot Lenny.
And then he shot Lenny,
and I was like why?
- So last time I cried was over
another person's wedding
video that I don't know.
- Okay.
But you cried at, like, the emotional
- The emotional, yeah.
- value, of like
someone else's wedding video.
- Yeah, I was like wow, that's impressive.
- The last time I cried,
I watched a video, oh god,
I watched a video of a dog.
It was one of those dogs where like,
you find them in like an abandoned area.
The person gets the dog, and
like shaves 'em, cleans 'em up.
Oh, god.
- It turns into a good dog.
- And it turns into a good dog!
They literally make me
tear up every single time.
Holy shit, this is so sour.
- I broke my headphones
the same week Trump won.
My grades were bad, I wasn't getting laid,
and my parents were mad at me,
and right then and there, I fell apart.
- So I was at school when I
got my Gucci sandals stolen.
Took my phone, my shoes,
and both of my Slides.
That's why I started to cry.
- I was watching Chef's Table on Netflix.
(laughing)
I was watching the episode
with Massimo Bottura.
Oh shoot, this is so intense.
I was watching the chef, it's
like really beautiful shots
of food, and I really love food.
This man's passion for
food is so beautiful.
This is crazy.
That TV show just makes
me cry every, oh my god.
I just love that show.
- Watching Moana.
When Moana's like, walking
down slo-mo down the mountain.
- [Man] Your eyes are so red.
- And she said bye to her grandmother.
I just thought it was really sad.
(laughing)
- When I got engaged.
We got engaged in Arizona on a creek.
It was just a really special moment.
- The last time I cried,
I think I was watching
Malcolm in the Middle,
and there was a highly
emotional part of the show.
Looked like a little kid
had died or somethin'.
(choking)
The bus flew in the
creek, and it was a bunch
of little kids in there.
And this particular kid, he
had, like, problems growing.
And this little guy saved
every little kid in the bus.
- Was it Simon Birch?
- Simon Birch, not Malcolm in the Middle.
(both laughing)
- I was about to say.
(upbeat music)
- I think men are completely
capable of emotion,
and anyone who says
like, no, that's not me,
I'm not emotional.
Then like, you're
suppressing important things,
and you're probably going
to have some sort of,
like, boil over at some point or another.
(upbeat music)
(sign squeaking)